Thompson quit cats
posting up the pace of the Raptors
really wants they forced the pace in
Game three Leonard's a pull-up drills to
jumper
draymond Green
pushing Thompson for three
Lowrey flipped like he had a layup there
they swing it and Leonard inches with a
3 Leonard gets it gonna have to shoot it
quickly he does and scores it was such a
smart play by Gasol Leonard turned
shoots his scores see some machine it's
good defense you've done your job
that's his tough shot by Ibaka cousins
to Thompson
Thaksin portray
of the matchup the smaller calorie about
the fifth time we've seen a post them up
mama call them clay i'ma call on clay
well I think they want to get more speed
on the floor as Leonard knocks the three
and the lead is cut to 1 well let's take
turns at over turn overs 11 to 4 only
for the Toronto Leonard knocks down
another three and the first lead of the
night full of raptors are you kidding me
you want though he's feeling on the
offensive end
draymond Green curry to Iguodala
Thompson thrills of the team confidence
that they really could be special
because his experiences two-way talents
as Thompson kept track this is where
piloted is so tough realizing that the
bonus you put so much pressure on you
trying to create contact Leonard pull-up
jumper drills it
with his ninth rebound Leonard pull-up
jumper but sit in Kawhi Leonard
dominating right now
[Applause]
[Music]
sadly the Leonard jumpers got it
how about Nick nurse giving COO island
and agree to the stock this fall and
tell you what about him I'm paying
attention to keeping them raptors
showing such poise here in this hostile
arena
Leonard open three knocks it down Kawhi
Leonard some basketball get off of that
pick-and-roll forcing them to make
decision and then what quality point
gods do make the proper read a 15-point
deficit facing the Golden State Warriors
Thompson finds some room that's a very
offensive decision green was old for 6
from the field before that coming off
that terrific game 3 they're gonna check
down see if that's a